como decíamos cerraron las urnas como
han transcurrido estos tres días de
votación
pues han transcurrido con numerosas
infracciones de tratar detectadas no
sólo por los observadores independientes
sino también por la propia comisión
electoral que ya ha invalidado más de
8.500 votos y hay que recordar que
acaban de terminar prácticamente está
recta final de las votaciones que han
estado vigentes durante tres días como
bien decía incluso también a través del
voto electrónico una modalidad que según
la oposición abre precisamente la puerta
a más fraudes por parte de las
autoridades rusas que se juegan mucho en
la votación de hoy porque putin necesita
seguir contando con esa súper mayoría
que le ha acompañado hasta la fecha para
poder seguir llevando a cabo su agenda
de reformas y no sólo eso sino también
poder volver a presentarse en 2024 sin
ninguna interferencia ni ninguna
oposición de los partidos políticos que
integran ahora mismo el parlamento ruso
mucha polémica salir en torno a estos
comicios polémicas que también rodean a
la participación de la oposición verdad
como sigue la oposición a estos comicios
sabemos que el grueso de los opositores
no pudieron participar y esto generó
polémica
si en efecto a todos los opositores
relacionados de una manera u otra con
álex in havana o con el movimiento
político del disidente aleccionaban y
ahora mismo está en prisión han quedado
automáticamente descalificados de estos
comicios aquí es donde el equipo de
naval y inventó lo que ellos llaman el
voto táctico es decir a través de una
app redirigían recomendaba en el voto a
sus seguidores a los representantes de
la oposición aunque fuesen del partido
comunista o del partido nacionalista que
estuviesen mejor posicionados para
arrebatar el escaño o el puesto a cada
uno de los representantes de alusión
idea que se presentaban en cada
demarcación pero recordemos que ese
sistema esa aplicación para incentivar
el voto táctico fue desbaratada hace
unos días y todo ha quedado en manos del
posible avance de los comunistas que
tienen a su favor el malestar de muchos
rusos con la situación económica actual
del país hablando de este avance de los
comunistas ayer se prevé por supuesto
que triunfe el oficialismo pero podría
ser por menos margen que en otras
oportunidades cuenta esto que decías
en efecto los primeros datos que nos
llegan ahora mismo por ejemplo la región
de jabárovsk que está en el extremo
oriente ruso y por tanto hace ya horas
que han cerrado las urnas hablando de un
importante avance del partido comunista
que ha incluso sobrepasado a rusia unida
en esa zona termina hay que recordar que
al encontrarse tan lejos de moscú existe
un fuerte descontento en algunas capas
de la sociedad que llevan años
reivindicando al gobierno que no se
olviden de esas regiones del oriente
ruso es decir de alguna manera es un
sitio donde los comunistas lo tenían un
poco más fácil pero desde luego marca
una tendencia para todo el país y
confirma lo que llevaban días diciendo
las encuestas que es que los comunistas
van a ser los grandes protagonistas de
la jornada y a partir de hoy tal vez
tendrán más fácil tratar de tú a tú con
el kremlin